Zach low back here on the show how are
you Zach I'm hanging in there rich how
you doing I'm doing great so let's get
let's let's start from the top
the collide trade what does it mean for
the Raptors do you think Zach I think
it's uh it's it works in both directions
it can be sort of an all-in move for
next year we're upgrading from a sort of
a borderline star to a true superstar
that we've never really had before and
we're going all-in for the finals and it
also could work as step one toward
tearing down the team and like if Kauai
walks then the full rebuild is on and
and I think that's something that
Messiah Jiri has contemplated
essentially since he got the job and so
I did it's it's worth it given the price
if you don't think demar derozan is
going to be a part of the team in four
or five years then why not go for it and
you your piece starts with a a
conversation DeMar DeRozan had with
Masai Ujiri back in December I give you
the floor to recount that story Zach
yeah they just stayed they brought Tamar
into the office and said the whole brain
trust was there and said hey you know
you want to get this team to the next
level you want to be a life time player
here is it and if you want this team to
contend you know it's it's finally time
to start shooting threes and it was a
way of empowering him to do it it was a
show of faith in him and actual of
confidence and the work he had put in
and he and he did start shooting threes
and the team won 59 games and they just
weren't good enough in the end you know
and and and and so they ran into LeBron
again and and it was sort of just
everyone needed to wash the taste of
that out of their mouth and that's
resulted in a coach being gone and a
star being gone what do you think the
plan on selling Kawhi on Toronto looks
like Zach well Messiah is a very
charismatic guy who connects well with
players and I think he'll he'll be the
lead salesman and I think the plan is
simple is like look you got play like
you're a superstar player you don't have
a lot of chances to compete you know you
only have 15 years in the NBA period you
can compete to make the finals here this
is a great city and you know maybe it
turns out he you can try and film hey
it's a big city he's got all the
benefits of the big city but the media
glare isn't what it is in LA in New York
and and maybe that appeals to him and
you know what maybe winning appeals
they have crazy crowds there like there
there is a lot to sell there and when it
all comes down to it what does it mean
in the East with the Celtics being who
they are Marcus smart getting signed up
by the Celtics just this a.m. and
Hayward coming back we assume looking
like Hayward and Calliste Kyrie there
for at least another year I mean what do
you think that means yeah if the if this
is the Raptors roster you know they got
to make a couple additions on the
fringes but they have a really versatile
roster with like a lot of wings who can
switch and shoot threes Danny Green is
gonna help them they keep CJ miles they
keep in a knowbut and an OB they keep
all their point guards Kyle Lowry zan
all-star I think they're gonna be a
really good team I think they're clearly
better than Philly I would put them a
tick behind Boston other people with
them and tick above Boston I think the
Celtics have a chance to be absolutely
special next season but Toronto is gonna
be a handful like 60 wins special I
would yeah I mean I they won 54 last
year and they're getting arguably their
two best players back I mean that's kind
of scary
yeah Jason Tatum he's so damn good I
mean he's so he's like Spees he's like
first team all-star special that's what
I'm talking about like starting in an
all-star game first team everything I
think he's that good Zac obviously I'm
not going down deep on a limb on that
front but it's it's tough to see how
that this puts the Raptors unless Kawhi
is is truly as back I mean what's the
concern on the medical before we move to
the Spurs here yeah I mean he's gonna go
through a physical at some point and and
we're gonna find out and pop I think
said in his his brief news conference
yesterday that they're they're pretty
confident he would have been 100%
healthy and you stayed with the Spurs
going to the next season so he's
probably good and as you said you know
that's that's what everyone's gonna be
watching for cuz in the in the nine
games he played last year which is
essentially nothing
he wasn't the MVP candidate top three
top floor player that he had been the
year before and if he's that guy Toronto
is dangerous that if he's not that guy
they're still good but they're not
dangerous
senior NBA reporter espn.com Zach Lowe
here on the Richardson show so what does
a trade mean for the Spurs
uh I think it means that they're pretty
good just like they were last year and
I'm not sure what their paths to ever
being great again is but I don't you
know they're bad pass was Kawhi Leonard
being a top three player and carrying
the team into the next era and DeMar as
good as he is is a step down from that
they'll be competitive because that's
what the Spurs do but they clearly made
a choice here we are not rebuilding we
are not going all in and getting four
picks from Boston it may be even a
couple of really good ones that could
help us five six years from now and
really lay the foundation for what we
hope is an expert iam we're gonna try
and stay relevant and the risk of that
is you get sort of trapped into
long-term mediocrity and that that is a
real risk for them though so then what
is this the best deal that they could
have gotten do you think for Kauai walk
me through what you heard about the
shopping process here and why he wound
up why the Spurs chose this deal it
depends what you want right I mean if
you're if you want to win right now
chase 50 wins again get a proven
all-star level player I do think this is
the best deal they could have gotten
that's not the kind of deal I would have
made I would have gone the other way and
said and said okay it's time now to
transition it's time to trade LaMarcus
it's time to do what we did before we
got to him Duncan and then I would have
I would have bid the Celtics and the
Sixers and you know who knows what other
teams might have might have thrown three
four picks into it or two or three picks
and a couple of good young players maybe
Miami would have done that maybe Phoenix
would have done that I doubt it in in
the case of a team that's so bad like
Phoenix but I would have bid those teams
against each other and I bet they could
have gotten a really nice deal full of
draft picks from a team like the Celtics
and they just didn't want that kind of
deal and that's their prerogative that's
Gregg Popovich's prerogative he's earned
the right to say I want to finish my
career coach in a winter so do you think
it's is it fair to say it's the first
time that that has ever been a
consideration
obviously Popovich is never been at the
end of a career before but it seems like
the the first time that his thought
prior legacy or end game
plays a role into the grocery shopping
there Zach yeah it's more that they've
just been so good at transitioning the
baton from Duncan to sort of Parker and
Ginobili together and then the moment
that you thought okay you know 2010/2011
you get rolled out the playoffs pretty
easily two years in a row like this is
the time where they're finally gonna
have to transition the update rate for
Hawaii and Kauai is the guy who takes
them into the next era and they just
have it had to sort of face this
question I mean they never make trades
their last big trade was the one for
Kawhi Leonard and you know some of it is
popping at the under career and some of
it is just they just haven't been in
this position before and I don't think
they were comfortable with the idea of
bottoming out yeah and then you know in
terms of what it means for the NBA cuz
that's again the title of Zach Lowe's
new column it was just again must read
on on ESPN what the kawatche trade means
for raptor Spurs and NBA I said on my
show yesterday the NBA has got to be
happy with this because at least at
least another super team has not been
created and that the Raptors are a team
that is more than viable in the East and
the Spurs get an intriguing player back
what do you think this means for the NBA
Zach yeah if somebody went from the west
to the east
it's nice when that happens for the
league it's interesting I think what it
what it really is that the biggest story
of the offseason is that they're they're
gonna be as many as 12 or 13 teams in
the West with playoff aspirations and
very legitimate ones I mean everyone was
thinking okay maybe you know the Lakers
are gonna go in because they got LeBron
so someone's got to fall out okay maybe
it'll be the Spurs because they're gonna
trade Kauai and that will be a big step
back for them and the Spurs aren't going
anywhere I mean I don't know if they're
gonna make the playoffs next year but
they're gonna be really they're gonna be
good and they're gonna try to and it's
just they're gonna be four or five teams
in the West next year that missed the
playoffs and are going to be crushed and
that's an unusually high number what are
the odds that one of those teams the
Lakers
I'm never betting against LeBron it's
finishing in the top eight of a
conference I almost don't even care who
the supporting cast is and I was deep
the conference's it's he's just too good
for me to to think it unless he misses
games or something that they're gonna
finish nine
than any conference so what is the
Lakers maneuvering right now just is
there any chance you think that they
call Toronto around December January
kicked the tires based on how the first
half of the season is going I mean what
do you think the game plan is now for
the palinka Magic Bus group Zach yeah I
think they'd look at it I mean if
everyone involved gets a sense that it's
not working in Toronto and he's gonna
leave they would have to read the tea
leaves and say see you know what are our
chances of just signing him out right
and if not how much value do we place on
getting them in the door now getting his
bird rights and can we do it without
trading Brandon Ingram and if we can
maybe maybe we do it I mean there is a
value and that kind of certainty there's
also a value in keeping as many of your
good young guys as you can for whatever
LeBron is aging or not on the team
anymore and you know I think they've
made the right choice and playing it
this way because there someone is going
there LeBron in Los Angeles and cap
space if it's not Kawhi it's gonna be
somebody and I think they're right to
bank on this so if we turn back the
clock one month Zach Lowe well you're
getting ready for the draft everybody's
getting ready for the draft and I told
you Kauai and Toronto Paul George stays
put boogie cousins with the Warriors
which one would make you stop and say no
chance probably boogie to the Warriors
even though was even though it was
pretty obvious that he wasn't gonna have
a big market once Dallas spent its cap
space on DeAndre they just he just never
could connected all the dots all the way
to get to Golden State it just it just
seems too ridiculous on its face to have
ever happened even though when you look
at it it's not so ridiculous just like
really golden state so that would have
been the one where I thought where I
would have thought but something weird
happened here and who's coming out of
the summer league with the Donovan
Mitchell vibe that people saying look
out for this kid this fall I like some
of the young bigs
what when del Carter jr. is going to be
a player in Chicago from what I saw on
what scouts saw the way he the owl or
for comparison gets thrown around a lot
and you definitely saw some of that and
jaren Jackson and Memphis is is going to
be a lot of fun on it and I'm again a
team with a lot of veterans that's
trying to make the playoffs next year
it'll be interesting to see
what kind of role he is Zach thanks for
the call appreciate it great stuff as
usual no problem have a good one you bet
that's at Zach low underscore NBA on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience